lovely to meet both of you it's such an
honor I'm I'm so excited to talk to you
about this show I mean it was a
fantastic experience watching it even as
an American who's not super familiar
with you know anything to do with
British politics much less the insanity
that is the story so we didn't know
anything about it either well I didn't
Kevin did but I it's both I did I lived
I lived through the story so you know so
I was going to ask if you had
familiarity with it I know Matthew you
said you were you were quite Young when
it when it happened so I was well I was
I was born in 74 which was the year that
he um did the deed that he flew to Miami
and left his clothes on the beach
the shimmering Sands Hotel yeah so I
didn't know about it but there was
weirdly there was a story there was
there was a a TV a book which was made
into a TV show with with Leonard roster
called the rise and fall of Reginald
parent about a man who
faked his own death and swam into the
Seas that's right that came after Woods
I think yeah right I think it was sort
of inspired by it I think right yeah
but I didn't know anything about student
house yeah and I was curious sort of in
that sense when you're playing a real
person because I know you both have done
it in the past obviously some things are
are dramatized for a television or film
or whatever so when you're how much
research are you doing and how much are
you just relying on what's on the page
I don't know I think I
I don't know whether you'd agree with
this but you do you sort of do
you still do as much research as you
fancy really it's the thing I don't
think you sort of and there are and it
depends on the style of thing you're
doing so if it's if it's a really
realistic sort of story
I mean you know if you're if you're
trying to depict it as accurately as
possible it's a different type of
research I suppose but there always
comes a point and I haven't done it very
much but whenever I'm playing a real
person there's always a point I think
right
forget the real I've just got to play
The Script because you can't play the
research you can't play the real events
because you have to play the text you
have to play The Story You're shooting
um it's like reading it's like reading
the source novel of a of a screenplay of
a classic you know it's helpful up to a
point but you're you're shooting the
script and not the novel you know yes I
I would say add to that in that but but
I would say uh Stonehouse is actually
although it's you know sort of Broad and
absurd and it's very funny and it's a
very well told story it's actually
closer to the truest the true story than
many things I've ever seen in particular
I remember it came in for a great deal
of criticism in the name of the father
and whatever Trump's role as the
defender the ridiculous story they made
up about her looking at park benches and
stuff when actually it was shared dogged
um boring police work that caught the
Guildford four which is what it was
about the IRA bombers
um
and I and I've seen other shows that are
based on true stories that do have some
do have some stretches of truth that I
think well why do you need to do that
you might stay with the original story
and having um narrated uh the
complimentary documentary the real
Stonehouse for this watch that
um and you'll see that there really
aren't any Liberty if anything we've
just left a load of stuff out there
wasn't time for but I don't see anything
invented in it at all no yeah yeah I
mean I I read the sort of I did a deep
dive I read the the Wikipedia page on
Johnstone house and I was shocked at how
sort of beat by beat everything is which
is obviously not something you see in in
sort of inspired by true story things so
no you know exactly yeah yeah but is is
there any sort of difference or is it
more difficult to play a real person do
you think than someone who's sort of
wholly made up for the the page or is it
you know similar in that sense it's
always a sort of weird I don't know
sometimes you feel a weird sort of
responsibility and sometimes it's a
slightly well I I feel a sort of awkward
feeling sometimes
but again there's a there's a jumping
off point you think
you know I can't worry about that I have
to just jump in and hope for the best
and Trust the director and the you know
will tell the story in the right way and
and also by the time you get to day one
of shooting there's a lot of
you know
you've got to have faith in the story
and a lot of work has been done with a
lot of legal work has been done to make
sure you're not sort of you know
giving a false impression of someone's
life story or you know because it's odd
because you're dealing with people whose
relatives are still alive and all the
rest of it so
it's a strange one sometimes
it isn't weird hybrid really yeah I I I
I felt I mean I I do think we've stopped
as well but I I thought to Matthew did
really recreate
um uh John Stonehouse uh brilliantly um
I felt that A Little Bit Stronger
because there's so much more footage of
Harold Wilson and he's so much more well
known to English people but but
fortunately I had lived through
um you know my teenage years with him
being prime minister so he was he was
well in there you know no I didn't have
to think about it too much just do the
scenes and Matthew you worked with your
wife Keeley Hawes on this and I know
you've worked together a couple of times
before but
particularly for this project
the characters are so intertwined you
know what was that like especially
because you do get kind of battered by
her she does yell at you many times
throughout the course of a couple
episodes yeah I would we just had a
really really great time we had a really
nice time just I mean
apart from anything else just
domestically it was really nice to hang
out
you know usually we're like we're
scattered and you know trying to sort of
keep the plate spinning but it was
really nice to go to work together
sort of see see each other yeah and you
you've also done um you did quiz back in
2020 which is also sort of inspired by
this sort of I guess to to use the title
of of what the writer of this show is
but like a very British Scandal is there
something specifically that draws you to
those projects like the kind of based on
a true story or anything or is it just
no Just Pure good fortune that those
scripts came came through my door that
was just yeah
so is there anything particular that for
either of you that draws you to a
project especially something like Stone
House
I think you know when you re when you
read a script you think this is great
you know I mean it's just it's as a
visceral feeling of this is a great
story you know I could do something with
this and
it's just in a writing so often you cut
you know I sort of tore through John's
script it's so brilliantly written it's
so sort of light and funny and
um and not and yet not sort of surface
it was just a it was a great thing to
read I always say that um if I can get
past page 11 on the first reading
um it's probably got a good chance yeah
because if you read if you read you know
you read anything I can't I you know
Life's Too Short yeah I mean you can
usually tell within the first 10 pages
if if it's ready really I mean something
might be good but it might not be ready
it might need a lot more work yeah
definitely yeah that makes and I read
Stoners in one sitting and then I read
it again yeah yeah yeah oh that's
fantastic but I think basically trying
to search for scenes that I was in you
know to help them more of bloody Matthew
McFadden
yeah well I think because this is It's a
period drama obviously it's not sort of
super far set back in the past you know
it's not 19th century it's it's 1970s
you know when my parents were alive
obviously when you guys were alive so
why do you think now is a good time to
tell this story I think it was I think
it might it might as well be like 1870 I
mean it's so different just just the
notion of just the reality of being able
to disappear
it's inconceivable now so yeah um it was
it it really I mean it sort of is a real
period piece I mean even going back to
the 90s as a period piece I remember did
something and a few years ago and it was
things things have sort of changing so
rapidly
um
I jumped in on the question sorry it
distracted it yeah that's fine it's fine
I was thinking in terms of especially
you know in terms of the idea of sort of
evading you know the truth evading
consequences you know that does still
strike very heavily today do you think
sort of thematically it's despite the
fact that you know it's the 70s and you
know everybody's in the polyester and
the you know in the wigs and everything
that it does still strike pretty true
yeah because I think the the the other
side of what Matthew's saying is that um
people's into relationships and and what
power and success does to people is the
same generation to generation really I'm
just still suffering from the fact that
I was doing check off at Rada when he
was born that's been really rearing on
my mind actually
sorry
but you're right human behavior hasn't
changed whether you're in a polyester
suit or whether you've got a mobile and
you know airpods it's just or you're in
britches and a horse you know on a horse
yeah it's the same it's the same
same stuff
vanities and pride and anger and love
and all the rest of it yeah yeah and I
think that that kind of ties back into
my my last question for you guys which
is sort of other than the fact that
truth is Stranger Than Fiction what are
you hoping that people will take away
from the story
I hope they really enjoy I hope they
have a really great time watching it I
mean I think it's really funny and
really interesting
um so I hope yeah I hope that they're
royally
um
entertained
and also think a little bit about
power and what it does to you yeah I I
would agree totally with Matthew on that
it's um
it's primarily an entertainment but an
entertainment that is that is leached
out of real events and and real things
that happened well I can say for certain
that I absolutely had a blast watching
it so thank you guys so much
thank you you're welcome cheers